michael link erst wahlbeobachter für die
osze guten abend herr link ja es ist
nicht so einfach die situation in
amerika gerade vor einem präsident
donald trump erhebt schwere vorwürfe
jetzt schon gegen die wahl dagegen wie
das ganze in seinen augen abgelaufen
sein soll
wie beobachten sie jetzt die situation
im land of the free ja das land of the
free hat in der tat spannende stunden
gerade vor sich
das wird jetzt die nächsten 24 stunden
die zeit sein in der nicht nur das
ergebnis kommt das ist ebenfalls ein
gefühl unsere mission die wir hier
hatten insgesamt über 100 beobachteten
die ich leiten darf hier als
bundestagsabgeordnete der fdp
die war sehr lange im land sechs wochen
waren die ganze zeit beobachtet da am
wahltag selbst dann noch sehr viele
parlamentarier
wir haben das gefühl jetzt ist wirklich
die entscheidung fällig und dann kommt
es hauptsächlich darauf an wie wird die
übergabe der macht laufen natürlich
offiziell ist die abens einführung erst
in 20 januar
aber da möchte ich die zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer darauf hinweisen
die märkte stunden werden entscheidet
entscheiden wie die ja wie das klima ist
wie das abläuft denn der amtsinhaber
wenn trump tatsächlich verlieren sollte
alle umfragen und vor allem alle
ergebnisse und auszählungen aussehen
dann wird es darauf ankommen dass klar
und deutlich auch ein friedlicher
übergang der macht stattfindet also dass
er das weiße haus räumt und auf der
anderen seite auch das beiden auch
ordnungsgemäß übernehmen kann das steht
jetzt in den nächsten 24 stunden an
vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen länger
wie werden sie jetzt gibt es aber die
vorwürfe von donald trump die ja fast
jeden tag wiederholt sie haben mit
kollegen die wahl beobachtet ist ihnen
etwas aufgefallen haben sie listen
gesehen wo tote gewählt haben haben sie
menschen treffen können die gesagt haben
wir konnten unsere stimme nicht
ordnungsgemäß abgegeben
wir haben in der tat auch probleme
gesehen
hier konnten sie allerdings alle in den
bereich der technischen probleme oder
fehler oder auch menschlichen fehler
oder auch schlampereien all das
geschieht ja bei wahlen denken sie nur
an den skandal vor einigen jahren bei
der österreichischen präsidentenwahl
bundespräsidentenwahl als die briefwahl
nicht richtig ausgezählt wurde
damals war auch klar das war schlamperei
aber da war kein system dahinter und das
war diesmal auch so wir haben als
internationale wahlbeobachter sehr eng
zusammengearbeitet mit den über 10.000
inländischen wahlbeobachtern
es gab das kann ich ihnen klar sagen
keine hinweise auf systematische fehler
auf fälschungen die geplant waren auf
betrug oder bewusste manipulation und
ich glaube das ist eine wichtige
erkenntnis dass man sagen kann die
vorwürfe des präsidenten das wahlsystem
seiter ob die briefwahl eigentlich
glaubwürdig dass dafür keine belege
vorlegen kann da will ich dann doch noch
einmal nachhaken sie sagen es gab
schlampereien wie muss man sich das
vorstellen was waren das für schlamperei
es gibt zum beispiel in der tat es gab
fälle wo briefwahlunterlagen in
einzelfällen mal nicht korrekt gezählt
wurden
das wichtige ist so was kommt heraus so
was wird bekannt dann kann auch
nachgereicht werden
ein altes problem bei den usa was nicht
neues was auch bei früheren wahlen schon
da war ist es in die wählerregister in
der tat gibt es immer wieder vereinzelt
fälle wo jemand entweder gar nicht
wählen kann weil er zum beispiel
umgezogen ist vom start an nachdem und
deshalb im alten register rausgeflogen
ist und im neuen noch nicht drin ist
oder er ist in beiden registern noch
drin welt doppelt auch das kommt vor
das sind aber einzelfälle das war kein
massenphänomen was die ergebnisse
beeinflussen würde
man muss wissen dass war das system in
den usa ist ganz anders als bei uns es
ist total dezentral jeder landkreis hat
sein eigenes system wieder staat hat
sein eigenes recht und das führt
natürlich dazu dass es war das system
schon auch sehr will man sagen manchmal
unübersichtlich ist da könnte man
durchaus einige unter anderem noch
reformieren können sie uns denn sagen
bei den fehlern die aufgetreten sind die
erkannt worden sind ob man dort bemerken
konnte ob das vor allem die
republikanischen stimmen oder
demokratische stimmen beeinflusst hat
nee das kann man nicht raus bekommen
weil es ja die geheim das geheimnis der
wale
das wurde gewahrt die wahl die als
sozusagen die fehler die gesehen wurden
wenn vereinzelt welche gesehen wurden
dann weiß wie gesagt vereinzelt dass er
das gesamtergebnis nicht beeinflusst im
gegenteil die usa haben gerade mit
briefwahl eine sehr sehr große erfahrung
ohnehin muss man bei so einem wahlkampf
wie den usa sehr sehr genau nicht nur in
den wahltag schauen sondern vor allem
auf die zeit vorher denn wenn es so
bliebe gibt den usa das hat unsere
beobachtung auch gerade gezeigt dann ist
ist er über komplizierte wahlrecht die
wählerregistrierung sehr kompliziert
anders als bei uns bekommt man keine
postkarte nach hause und geht dann zur
wahl sondern muss alles selbst machen
und diese sehr aufwendige wahlprozess
der teilweise geld als
verwaltungsgebühren kostet der teilweise
aufwendig ist das ist eher das problem
also wir haben eher administrative
technische probleme gesehen aber keine
manipulation die in irgendeiner weise
die eine oder andere seite politisch
bevorzugt oder benachteiligt hätte jetzt
gab es heute einen regelrechten skandal
darum dass mehrere sender die rede von
präsident donald trump unterbrochen
haben in der er darüber gesprochen hat
dass wenn es um liegl woods gehen würde
er schon gewonnen hätte und nur die
illegalen stimmen ihnen jetzt davon
abhalten würden wie gefährlich sind
solche aussagen von der regierung und
vor allem vom amtierenden präsidenten
für das für die wahlen und vor allem für
das vertrauen der menschen in die wahl
wir haben das in unserem offiziellen
bericht in den fokus gestellt haben
haben wir es war nicht das erste mal
dass er sagte haben wir das sehr stark
kritisiert weil er das vertrauen der
bürgerinnen und bürger der wähler in den
wahlprozess dadurch zerstört und das ist
schon ein problem mit den amtsinhaber
selbst dafür sorgt dass das vertrauen in
das system zerstört wird
der führende republikanische war experte
ginsberg gerade jetzt vor wenigen
minuten in cnn
das ist der wahlrechts kuba in
republikaner hat es ja schon auf den
punkt gebracht er hat gesagt kein
vorwurf sei er noch so bombastisch wenn
er nicht belegt ist dann ist er nicht
berechtigt
und genau das ist das problem auch was
die rechtsanwälte von trump bisher
vorgelegt haben reicht nicht dafür dass
ein gericht bisher wirklich tätig
geworden wäre
wahrscheinlich wird es noch
gerichtsurteile geben unsere experten
gehen nicht davon aus dass das erfolg
haben wird auch der supreme court in den
usa ist anders als auch behauptet nicht
parteipolitisch einseitig sondern er
klar er ist natürlich vorgeschlagen von
republikaner demokraten die einzelnen
richter aber wie bei uns auch die
verfassungsrichter werden bei uns auch
für den parteien vorgeschlagen kann man
nicht sagen dass der
verfassungsgerichtshof einseitig
arbeiten würde ich glaube dass die
institutionen in den usa stark sind dass
sie unabhängig sind und dass sie jetzt
gerade in dieser zeit zeigen dass sie
auch mit so einer herausforderung einer
komplexen wahl zurechtkommen ferling das
eine ist was in den bei den wahlen
passiert ist das andere ist was
sozusagen dann nach der ausbildung
während der auszählung draußen passiert
ist und wir wollen uns da noch einmal
ein paar bilder anschauen was dort
draußen los war
demonstranten die für trump auf die
straße gehen
[Musik]
lehrling wenn sie diese bilder sehen wie
viele sorgen macht ihnen das wenn sie
das erleben und sehen dass es da auch
möglicherweise noch zu gewalttätigen
szenen kommen könnte ich glaube wir
müssen ein bisschen die kirche im dorf
lassen dass eine wahl umstritten ist
dass die gemüter hochkochen
das gehörten der demokratie dazu mir ist
eine demokratie lieber in dem erst mal
hoch hergeht als staaten in denen nehmen
sie zum beispiel russland in denen die
wahl letzten endes eine ziemliche farce
ist weil es eigentlich dort gar keine
freie wahl mehr gibt hier gibt es eine
freie wahlen den usa
das hat unsere beobachtung auch gezeigt
es ist eine wahl bei der man eine echte
auswahl hat zwischen zwei verschiedenen
kandidaten und zwei völlig verschiedenen
politischen konzepten das ist eigentlich
gut für die demokratie aber klar ist
auch wenn jetzt demonstriert wird zum
beispiel nach dem wahlergebnis
dann ist es ganz wichtig dass beide
seiten der verlierer der gewinner alles
dafür tun dass es friedlich bleibt und
das ergebnis akzeptiert wird und da
würde ich mir schon deutliche worte des
jetzigen präsidenten wünschen der nicht
noch öl ins feuer gießt sondern der
dafür sorgt dass das wahlergebnis
akzeptiert wird zu ende ausgezählt wird
natürlich zunächst und hinterher dann
auch eine friedliche übergabe
stattfindet falls tatsächlich die
mehrheit für die briten ist wir sind
bild und wir liefern dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren